chief referenced beating down doors
knocking down doors a few times what
does that entail and how can one do it
graciously or maybe on servers hi I
think you have to have a lot of patience
and you have to know that it's not one
phone call that its many phone calls
that you'll be making that you'll come
back to the same people over and over
and over again it's a it's a matter of
getting people comfortable with you of
getting them on your side so instead of
thinking that you're going out to raise
money you have to think that you're
going out to woo people to bring them
into your camp to make them part of your
support system to just get their
enthusiasm for your project and you know
if the money isn't forthcoming
immediately that doesn't mean it's not
going to come in the long run and it
doesn't mean that they're not going to
be able to help you in some other way so
I think it's almost like gathering your
tribe around your project getting people
who see your passion and believe in you
so I think that's the attitude you have
to go in with so when is no really you
know sometimes I think people say well
they don't take no for an answer but I
think sometimes the person like to say
no not to be malicious but may need to
stay truly can't give it whatever it is
that you are asking for and how do you
still interact that person
I think that you have to have a real
sense of of where people are coming from
of what's going on with them that makes
this possible for them or not and you
have to live within the reality of that
and maybe a no is a no now but is not a
no in the future and and then they you
know there's some people who say take me
off your list well if they say that then
it's a no it's it okay we're sorry we
bothered you and you know you have to do
that too because you will be bothering a
lot of people who don't want to be
bothered about this who have their own
problems or their own projects that
they're raising money for so you just
have to be very sensitive every step of
the way and I think to responding to
someone that maybe does they take you
you know take me off the list and doing
in a pleasant way or at least closing
the door in a favorable way because
we're hurt you know we feel like oh they
don't believe in us I don't think you
can afford to be hurt yeah your personal
feelings have got to be left on the
doorstep somewhere else you are in a
very very difficult and dynamic
situation when you're fundraising and
there really is no room for personal
feelings of her to rejection that you
got to just get rid of that it's not
useful to you in any way this is just a
job you're doing and you won't be
successful at every phase of it but
overall you will be successful and
that's what you look for and that same
notion would apply as well to actually
just be in the business whether an actor
filmmaker composer we'll have you right
yes it is not an easy business and if
you do that but if someone
or what is said to develop Rhino skin
we're just stuff just doesn't affect you
anymore was that something that you were
able to do over a course of time or were
you always pretty thick skin no no I was
not thick skin I was your typical
fragile young girl who was easily hurt
but you know you learned you'd get out
there and you tough it out and you learn
and and that's what you do and then all
of a sudden you wake up one day it's
like hey you know that doesn't bother me
anymore I don't care who are they yeah
you're you're who you are and that's
that's what you're searching for all the
time and once you find that once you
find your own personal strength nobody
can shake that I have a little sign that
I put on my computer that another
producer said I found it and I've heard
of some magazine said if anyone says no
to you and you're discouraged for one
second you're dead oh okay meaning I
cannot indulge myself in any kind of
self-pity whatsoever I got too many
other people to talk to her going to say
yes that has been a real help for me
you